The Curious Case of Captain Robert Campbell
Captain Robert Campbell began his British
Army career in 1903 at the age of 18.
Shortly after WWI started, in July of 1914
Campbell and the soldiers he was leading,
the First Battalion East Surrey Regiment,
were sent to Mons-Condé canal in the north
west of France.
One week later, after an attack by German
forces, Captain Campbell was seriously injured
and ultimately captured.
He was then treated in a German military hospital
in Cologne, and, once healed up a bit, sent
to the prisoner-of-war (POW) camp in Magdeburg,
Germany.
None of this makes Captain Campbell particularly
unique in the “War to End All Wars.”
Between 1914 and 1918, approximately 10 million
civilians and servicemen were captured and
interred at various detention camps.
What makes Campbell’s story different is
something that happened two years after his
capture.
Now in his early 30s, Captain Campbell received
word that his mother, Louise, was suffering
from terminal cancer.
With nothing to lose, Campbell wrote directly
to Kaiser Wilhelm II, requesting compassionate
leave so that he might see her before she
passed.
Surprisingly, the Kaiser agreed, granting
him two weeks leave provided he “gave his
word as a British Army officer that he would
return.”
After giving his word, Captain Campbell was
indeed released.
Details of how he actually made it home have
been lost to history, but it is thought that
he traveled through the Netherlands and then
took a boat to Kent.
Upon arriving home, he spent a week with his
mother before returning to the POW camp by
equally mysterious means.
campbell-leave-of-absenceThere was no recorded
explanation in the British military archives
why no one in the army tried to block his
return, but presumably a British officer’s
honor being at stake had something to do with
it.
Whatever the case, in February of 1917, Captain
Campbell’s mother died while he was still
a prisoner.
Perhaps to keep himself occupied, and said
to be a matter of honor and duty, as soon
as Captain Campbell returned to the prison
camp, he and a group of other prisoners spent
the next nine months digging a tunnel out
of their camp.
This tunnel project was partially successful
in that they were able to use it to escape
the camp, but were caught near the border
of the Netherlands and sent back.
While you may think that Captain Campbell’s
story and the show of mercy and good faith
on Kaiser Wilhelm II’s part might have inspired
the British to do the same, this was not the
case.
German POW Peter Gastreich was being held
at the Isle of Wight when he learned his father
was dying.
He then asked for a leave of absence to go
seem him, but the British Prisoners of War
Department summarily ruled against this, stating,
they
“Cannot recognise the temporary release,
on parole, of Captain Campbell as a precedent
for such concessions.
They were not consulted before leave was granted
to the Officer by the German Government and
would not have consented to such a proposal
had it been put before them.”
At the war’s end, along with the other POWs,
Captain Campbell was released and remained
in the Army until he retired in 1925.
When WWII began, Campbell rejoined the army
and served as the Chief Observer of the Royal
Observer Corps on the Isle of Wight.
He lived to the ripe old age of 81.
ultimately dying
in 1966.